let's talk about one of the best
remedies to act as an antihistamine now
histamine is involved in the immune
reaction
it's the thing that produces a lot of
the symptoms that are related to an
allergy the problem is that sometimes
the body over responds or it
inappropriately responds
to
a potential allergen and you get a
series of very
uncomfortable symptoms whether it's hay
fever runny nose itchy eyes well itchy
anywhere in the body flushing response
dermatitis that's inflammation of your
skin
photosensitivity that sensitivity to
the sun sneezing fatigue and even
wheezing because of the constriction of
your bronchial tubes and
the more histamine reaction you have the
more cortisol response you're going to
have too because cortisol is the natural
body chemical that helps to neutralize
these histamines and if someone has
adrenal fatigue or
let's say they have a low cortisol going
into some allergy reaction they're not
going to have this buffering effect or
antidote to histamines and so the
histamines are just going to rise way
too high so i want to give you a natural
remedy that you can use as needed to
help minimize these histamine symptoms
and this remedy is cursive tim kerosen
has been thoroughly studied
from a lot of different angles and
there's some really great studies that
i'm going to list down below that you
can check out so what does it do well it
inhibits
the cells that make histamines they're
called mast cells and so a mast cell is
an immune cell that releases histamines
and so if we can inhibit the mast cell
we can reduce the histamine piercing
also directly inhibits the histamine
response and it also stabilizes the mast
cell membrane which is exactly how a lot
of antihistamines work so you can look
at kerosene as a natural zyrtec it will
reduce mucus
and inflammation as well now there's
several ways we get this natural plant
compound okay you can eat foods high in
quercetin which would be the red onion
especially the outer part
close to the root it's in capers it's in
kale
it's in dill and it's even radishes but
you can get kerosene in a supplement and
i would recommend taking it in
quantities between 400 and 600
milligrams depending on your size
and because there's a half-life of
kirsitin roughly about two hours i would
take it every two hours until you get
some significant relief now the thing
about these plant-based compounds is a
lot of them are fat soluble including
piercing so you would want to take it
with a little bit of fat to increase the
absorption
you can take it with a little bit of
coconut oil or butter all you need is
just a little bit now to increase the
bioavailability even more maybe you can
get curiositin with bromeline which is
another compound that can help you
absorb kerosene now this is a very
effective remedy but i'm not saying it's
going to work 100 of the time or it's
going to be 100 effective so i'm going
to give you several other things that
you can take that will enhance this
effect okay and vitamin d is at the top
of the list okay and i would take no
less than
20 000 iu's of vitamin d per day i would
also recommend taking zinc okay i would
take about 50 milligrams of zinc and the
last remedy that i really like
recommending would be
nettle root okay this is a great
anti-inflammatory it's great for
allergies it's great for inflammation so
depending on the severity of your
problem maybe you want to stick just
with piercing or add some of these
additional things to really create a
more potent effect now since we're on
the topic of the immune system i think
the next most appropriate video for you
to watch would be this one right here
check it out
you